this morning in our series vaccinating
america we're answering
your questions about vaccinations and
the projected holiday surge in covid
cases
cbs news chief medical correspondent dr
john lepuc is joining us now john good
morning good to see you
good morning happy new year's eve vlad
happy new year's eve so john two states
have now reported
cases of the new more contagious strain
of the coronavirus first reported in the
uk is it your estimation
that that strain of the virus is already
here in the united states given
that we've already seen it in two states
and more importantly will the current
vaccines approved work against it
vlad i think it's highly likely that it
is much more widely spread we just
haven't been looking for it
now that we're looking for it we'll find
it the good news and i confirm this with
tony fauci is that
the vaccine is still expected to work on
it
doc let's talk about the astrazeneca
vaccine approved in the uk how does that
compare to pfizer and modernist vaccine
you know david it works on the same
mechanism of trying to sneak in some
genetic material
that codes for this spike protein and to
get your body producing it
and that protein then acts sort of like
a scent would
for a bloodhound and then trains the
immune system to go out and be ready
for an infection in this case it's using
a virus called an adenovirus
you put dna in it it goes in it attacks
attaches to cells
the trick though is that the adenovirus
has been altered so it can't multiply
once it's inside you it's just another
way of getting genetic material inside
it
and it's the same kind of idea all right
doc let's get to our viewer questions
elizabeth on facebook asked this how
will we know when we can get the vaccine
and where to go to get it i think a lot
of people that's probably the number one
question i hear john
i mean i know when my parents who are
older in their 70s will get it but for
example
people who are not high risk or
essential workers what's the schedule
yeah well the cdc has put out a general
guideline right so the first is the
healthcare professionals
about 21 million of them and then and
also people in skilled nursing
facilities another 3 million
then you go down to people who are
frontline essential workers that's in
the 1b
group and people over 75 and then in 1c
you have people who are younger uh and
also
essential workers and then after that
you work down to people who are
say in their 20s or in their late teens
but the
the reason why everybody's so confused
is that you've got 50 different states
and it's the states that control exactly
the plan so it's like you had a football
game
and you had 50 different coaches and 50
different game plans no wonder why
people are confused
interesting let's go to an instagram
question doc so someone asked how
fast can you gain immunity after you
receive the vaccine
i have a friend here in new york city dr
lapook who is a doctor
he received his vaccine a week or so ago
five days later he tested positive for
coronavirus
so some people are wondering i didn't
think you could get the virus after you
get the vaccine what say you
in the studies it looks like the
immunity starts to kick in
at two weeks so unfortunately your
friend at five days didn't yet have
enough immunity
and then at two weeks it starts building
and then of course the full immunity
that was measured in the studies at
least was about
at about 28 days at about a month so you
start to get immunity about
two weeks a little bit too early at five
days interesting
here's a question from joanne john can a
vaccinated person
still transmit the virus
that's the million dollar question vlad
and uh
we don't know the answer to that we
think it's likely that there should be
protection against transmitting the
virus but
they're still looking at the data for
that and uh there's an asterisk there
we're we're not positive and that's why
they're saying look even though you get
the vaccine
you still have to wear the mask and do
everything else because you're not
positive
that even though you're feeling fine
that you couldn't possibly transmit it
to somebody else we should find out the
answer
hopefully in the near future john you
got your vaccine a week ago how you
feeling
i feel great i had about transient the
slightest of headaches maybe for a day
or two
a little sore arm but i feel terrific
and i'm i'm
so happy to have gotten it it was very
emotional to to get vaccinated not just
the relief but also the release i think
of all those
months of what we've all been going
through happy new year friend
happy new year happy new year good to
see you my friend happy new year to you
and your family